in the heart of Woodbury Connecticut
stands the state's oldest Inn the Curtis
house open in 1736 the 16-bedroom Inn
has been owned and run by the Hardesty
family for nearly 60 years and is
currently being run by Chris Hardesty
and his sister TJ the Curtis house is
haunted see
the rooms will all be done and the
comforters will be nice and neat and
tidy and you can go back in five minutes
later and it looks like somebody rolled
across it I would walk by a table and
two minutes later a plate would fly off
of it I went to light the fireplace and
it blew up on me and I got burned
there are spirits here but Spirits
aren't paying gas and the Curtis house
bedrooms are empty most nights right now
I would say we're about a hundred
thousand dollars in debt
my Dad recently passed away he had a
firm belief that my brother and I could
take over the end it just left me more
determined to succeed
failing to continue their father's
success with Ian has destroyed Chris and
TJ's relationship they hardly ever speak
and when they do they fight You're a
Mean horrible [__] we were married we'd
probably be divorced by now you come off
like this every time all the time she's
controlling she wants things done her
way because when I sit there and give a
rule
[Music]
frustrates me to the point where
sometimes I would like to just
bought them over the head to get rid of
some frustrations another woman who
doesn't listen to [__] thing I say
Chris and TJ's frustrations with each
other and their failing business have
made the in hell for staff
no my tray I don't give a [__] they just
don't care if you look at your boss who
doesn't care why are you going to care
TJ's not a great leader she yells at you
I've never heard a thank you I think you
can go a long ways Chris he's just a fat
lazy slob I [__] everywhere we will get
complaints from the customers we will
have problems with dishes it's just
Shrugged off he doesn't give a crap I've
lost respect for TJ and Christopher
we've lost a lot of customers because of
management
since TJ and Chris both took over
everything is going downhill
like a rusted saltwater did you have
your tetanus shot everything sucked give
me another please without answering
anything I would never come here again
if things don't improve and fast a
family Legacy could come to a tragic end
the Kurdish house is a huge thing to our
family we've been here for 59 years
we've all pretty much grown up here
Curtis house is like my second home
there has been all these years the same
with my mother and my aunts if the
Curtis house shut down it would really
feel like we lost a part of our family
I'm on my way to Curtis house it's
Connecticut's oldest thing I'm excited
about it because it's supposed to be one
of New England's historical gems there's
nothing wrong with being the oldest
just depends how much Botox you've had
I'm going to be arriving on a big day
for hotels and restaurants Across
America but there's something I've got
to do first
hello hi mum
are you I'm Vero thank you I'm just
bringing you to wish you happy Mother's
Day
oh thank you so much
thank you very much
well I'm sorry I can't be with you thank
you so much
let's have a great day love you lots
ah great here we are the Curtis house
as old as ill lovely
the Happy Mother's Day sign looks a bit
crap but I suppose it's the thought that
counts
look at this place
built before 1736 incredible
hi there Gordon nice to see you well
welcome to the Curtis house happy
Mother's Day thank you very much and
what's your first name babe I know
you're a baby what's your name Shirley
Shirley nice to see you my day so it's
Mother's Day the Russians booked today's
big day right yes is the hotel full not
tonight oh how many rooms of books just
one
just one yeah just me yes
yes so I'm a little bit early okay
usually check-in is three o'clock
there's usually a ten dollar an hour fee
that's what four hours of forty dollars
already yes so I could save a little bit
of money by hanging out and actually
going into the room yes
so I want to save myself 40 bucks yes so
if I just take a little nap
what are you doing
beer Mr Ramsey Gordon
[Music]
this isn't really appropriate I'm sorry
I'm joking but it doesn't make sense you
charge me ten dollars an hour if I just
hang out on the sofa get a little
blanket I can save myself some money
you know this rule actually went into
effect about six months ago this ten
dollar an hour I really think and is it
making a big impact on the business
people don't like it the bookings in the
rooms have definitely gone downhill I
think they would be a lot busier if TJ
didn't have these ridiculous rules
um is that right my details in here
credit card details yes we take a credit
card number to hold the room I
appreciate that but why put it in the
book that's the house Palestine if the
customer insists then we can erase it
once they check it
I've got the credit card details for
everybody I will have to call 9-1-1
I don't really have to call 9-1-1 do I
babe see by the time you've called 9-1-1
okay I've hacked into every credit card
in this book
I made myself a fortune so whose policy
is this a bit weird this is a house
policy um like TJ lights in the owner
yes would you not think there's a
security Bridge there that's why her
policy is no one to look in this book
except the desk person wow okay I can't
believe you're going to be in room 16.
why because room 16 has a ghost in it
this woman told me who went to room 16.
she said the ghost was pulling the
blankets offer all night long and you
haven't been drinking cherry
wow many years ago I was at the Curtis
house and people do tell us that she
raises a little bit of Havoc with them
she's definitely there
room 16.
a haunted dream
my goodness me
what is that on the footprint
come on no way so where's all that big
stuff yes it looks like a footprint to
me
and what's that in the dead bugs
oh dear oh geez but there's one here
I give him a list of the rooms that are
coming in they're supposed to thoroughly
check the room do we do we have
electricity in the house
I couldn't believe what I brought and
found in that room and what is this
nobody just realized her care how long
have you been working here well I've
been on since about 1965. how was it
then busy all the time what 48 years
that's incredible so this place means a
lot to you oh yes my second home are you
connected to the family in any way TJ's
parents and my mother were cousins
so it must be sad for you to see it
struggling yes definitely and why is it
struggling that's the way your two
bosses get along and was it different
when TJ and Chrissy's parents were
running it oh yeah much more
professional so why do you stay why'd
you put up with this I take pride in
this place I like this place I can see
that I really do but they don't
understand that the place is really
worth it I really think TJ and Karissa
are really hurting the business
somebody needs to knock some sense into
them first impressions
um there's no all my credit card details
downstairs in that book in such a
vulnerable position one of the busiest
weekends ever for this hotel Every
Mother's Day I'm the only one staying in
the hotel that's that's not good dust
everywhere and a windowsill full of bugs
I don't think I want to get possessed
staying here I think we've got a disease
all right go downstairs have a look
babe let me out
honestly it must be the bloody ghost
come on Betty let me out I just want to
get some lunch
I've just arrived at the Curtis house in
Woodbury Connecticut and they've given
me a room with a ghost and a door lock
that doesn't work at last I'm the only
guest in this hotel despite the fact
it's Mother's Day and the restaurant is
fully booked hey what a dreadful missed
opportunity
hello good afternoon how are you Chris
says I'm doing well sir how about you
this is hi my name is TJ TJ nice to meet
you Fiona yes nice to see you nice to
see you this is my mother happy Mother's
Day thank you very much uh it's an
absolute honor to meet you are you
working today I have worked every
holiday and never got paid ridiculous
you should be sad having lunch enjoying
this business
um should we go to the table we shall
time for me to see if the hotel's
restaurant is as bad as the bedrooms
right
my name is Karen I'll be taking care of
you are you connected to the family yes
I am I'm TJ and Uncle Chris's niece okay
nice and just in a nutshell um what's
wrong with the place now there's no
communication between my aunt and uncle
it's gotten a million times worse since
my grandfather passed away these shows
isn't it yeah
I just wanted to come here because my
family desperately needs his help
they've been struggling for way too long
they don't know what to do we really
need his help this is the dinner menu
wow what would you say
the cupcakes
yeah you yes it's not hesitation they're
hit or miss them they're hell Miss yeah
the cupcakes uh what else um I'll take
some calamari okay and John let's have a
little taste of burger how do you like
it medium rare please you're welcome
okay it's Mike all right listen this is
Ramsay crab cakes
calamari with Gorgonzola when he wants
the burger medium rare I am very proud
of my food whenever I eat other places I
think we're better than 90 of them do we
have calamari in a line or no
the crab cakes love it
um let's do this together do you mind
please come on you're supposed to be my
my wing man
I I had to swallow it was not enjoyable
Hit or Miss for me that's a Miss yeah
holy [__] these I warned you about it
thank you you're welcome
how was lunch my darling it wasn't very
good Everything feels institutional
right you know like we just got out of
the hospital and it's the best food we
could get I'm sorry it's not a nice
surprise for Mother's Day is it no it's
not calamari and then I'll have the pork
the burger a cocktail sauce fork and
lemon monkey dish for the marinara
so fried Calamar
can you hear any Christmas
my granddad's dick
oh my God oh my God oh my God that's
disgusting it's awful it's awful
yeah okay thank you you're welcome
so calamari was mostly greasy you know I
have to bring this food out you know
he's going to critique it and you know
I'm going to come right back within one
second because you don't care you're
just setting me like
[__] on a plate basically all right he's
a mushrooms Mike
my bad guy your burger thank you very
much Jesus where's my burger
what a mess did you tell them it's
medium rare
Jesus yes raw that is not Legion rare
what a shame that is Dreadful my uncle
can't cook a burger medium rare are you
freaking kidding me you can check me
through and introduce Mr chef of course
yeah thank you call your uncle yeah
Uncle Uncle Chris I can't believe how
bad my food was I've got to see the
kitchen in action for myself right back
here is my cousin Mike hi Jeff Chef
Ramsay this is Uncle Chris okay so TJ's
little brother yes my brother Mike
Trudeau
likewise and this is Cheyenne Cheyenne
[Music]
yeah
fire yeah mushroom wrap one all day in a
primavera
[Applause]
okay
am I okay yeah I'm completely 10 minutes
I'm amazed none of you even asked me how
would lunch was
what's most shocking isn't the food or
that they have zero interest in my
experience as a diner it's the fact that
Chris and his sister don't exchange a
single word they won't even look at each
other
atmosphere in here with a knife
hate mothers the way he's treating these
dishes we put food on a plate like
you're slopping it can I borrow that
cloth a minute
you're wiping plates with this
you don't care
I don't know about that
to say that not know me at all is
doesn't have any foundation
is anything cooked to order here
french fries salads french fries salads
[__]
20 [__] dollars ahead for that Chris
doesn't seem like an owner or a chef he
hasn't eaten cooking he's just heating
things up Chris you got two seconds
please here's where I'm getting
frustrated you own the place you cook
like you hate the place
come on Chris talk to me please
foreign
what's the point
the Curtis house in Woodbury Connecticut
is falling apart
because owners Chris and TJ won't talk
to each other and it's affecting the
Inn's guess as well as the food that is
Dreadful I don't know if there are
ghosts upstairs but there's definitely a
dead man walking in the kitchen
you own the place you cook like you hate
the place
this place is a mess it's like nobody
cares here one thing's for sure it is
not happy [__] families let me tell
you
all right ghost stories and legends of
Southwestern Connecticut wow room 16 is
host to a doting female paying special
attention to male guests staying in the
room she tucks them into the bed and may
even crawl next to them what at least
they've got one regular guest Betty it's
you okay
I didn't get a visit from Betty the
ghost but I still had a rough night's
sleep
feels so dusty after last night
oh man
this Inn has been in the Hardesty family
for four generations and I can't
understand why TJ and Chris have no
appreciation for what has been given to
them
I've called a staff meeting and I'm
hoping this will get them talking before
they lose their family heirloom that's
why I have a quick chat with you all
my first impressions have not been good
but I struggle to believe that you two
are brother and sister it is shocking no
communication not even looking at each
other
why can't you two at least talk to each
other get frustrated with some things
and all the time we talk and talk about
doing [__] we never get anything done
and you think this is what your father
wanted no it's absolutely not
what's wrong with this place I feel like
it was management you know a thank you
would be nice every once in a while you
know that's all I asked for I'm more
hurt than angry because I care so much
about them you sound like you've been
pushed the breaking point yeah I felt
like TJ and Christopher don't give a
[__] I don't know how much more I can
take
China when did the drive go out of the
kitchen when did the essence when did
the word passion disappear I've never
seen all three in that kitchen ever ever
I feel like I am The Voice of Truth
everybody else either one doesn't care
or two they just don't see it I've been
saying since day one that this kitchen
is a joke there are no standards in the
kitchen chef
pressing [__] Cheyenne his opinion
doesn't really matter to me never has
never will I watched you in the kitchen
it was like you were just hard as an
extra
TJ you're Feud with your brother is
clearly getting in the way of running
your business the staff are desperate
and you know what hurts
it's a blessing that you've got this
place the potential is huge yet you walk
around and treat it like it's a curse
I came to your Inn as a guest and I am
not [__] happy both of you are
sleepwalking to disaster
office and at least try to talk
don't talk you might as well close the
doors right now
you know in the 30 years I've been here
I never had anybody ever in complaint
like that and it makes it tough and then
throw it in my face even harder you know
foreign
he really gave me a wake-up call
because this place is toxic TJ has
issues I think she's a control freak and
you talking to them they're standing
there as far as I'm concerned they made
asses out of themselves
I'm done here
I cannot work here no more this is your
life this is yours yeah and it's
destroying I can say that
They Don't Care About Us
they need to hear from you
okay
I can't believe it's come to this as far
as I'm concerned TJ and Christopher
they're not gonna change it's a total
shame
okay
how are you
good
[Music]
yeah I can't
I can't work here anymore I'm sorry it's
destroying me
I don't like it
you know I care about every one of my
staff here you don't you make people
feel uncomfortable and I'm telling you I
don't know whether anybody else is going
to speak up I'm not saying that I'm
perfect by any means at all either but
you know I don't think that there should
be personal attack this is the way I
feel whether you guys like it or not
because it's just killing me I feel as
though there's no future I'm done
you're giving me a look like every
single bit of that is Justified a lot of
the [__] she says is true TJ nobody
wants to [__] talk teak I am not
going to have her tell me that I'm this
mean horrible monster that doesn't give
a [__] everybody thinks you're a mean
horrible [__]
everybody I really think you need to
[__] talk to somebody or do something
before you're in a padded [__] room
I disagree the proof is in the Putin
you're strung out you're [__] tweaked
right to the [__] end every day
because you don't have any help and then
you turn into a miserable [__] psycho
[__] shut the [__] up she didn't know
what she was [__] talking about and
she could drag her [__] ass did I
ever say anything to you
the broken relationship between the
owners of Connecticut's cut his house in
has gotten to an all-time low everybody
thinks you're a mean horrible [__] I
asked them to talk for the first time in
months but all they did was yell at each
other shut the [__] up
I'll keep this brief I've got to get
them to see if they don't communicate
this in or shut its doors
I don't know what it's going to take to
wake you up you've already lost one of
your employees because you can't get it
together you're starting to resent each
other and the work you're doing I I
agree but I think it's hard to come to
work knowing the minute you walk in the
door until you walk out the back door
there's a disagreement in every room
you're in it used to be that we talked
things through we just stopped doing it
it's been frustrated
frustrated every [__] day for three
years yeah you know if you got so
frustrated with me three years ago that
you just stopped talking it's horrible
every [__] time we talk or turn into
an argument and
it was just avoiding the arguments
you know just got [__] fed up
we're not talking three months
three years
when was the last time either of you
stayed here and see how the guests
experienced it through their eyes you've
never done it
shows
can both of you come with me please
there's something in my room I'd like to
show you
if Chris and TJ won't listen to each
other maybe they'll listen to the people
who could keep their business alive
please both of you take your stand over
there
here we have some guests and I think
you're gonna find that their feedback
invaluable
let's start off with you first just
pulling back the comforter honestly it
looked like the sheets hadn't been
changed and the chair kind of picked up
the cushion and there was
for lack of a better word a skid mark on
on it was disgusting the pools had some
stains on them
insects on the window sills it looks
like the windows haven't been washed in
a while we have flowers like in here
they had like an inch of dust on them
we did that door we had a wicker like
divider and when you tried to pull it it
just kind of Falls over
jump in guys I mean you know these are
customers that are paying money it's
very disheartening I've never got
responses like this before and
I wish I had
can I talk to you about the arrival when
you arrive you hand over your personal
credit card details addresses your cell
numbers what do you think happens to
your details after you've left
because in this book
is all of your credit card details
oh here we go this is it this is the
hammer it is Vital Information of your
credit card details your addresses your
cell numbers in black and white
this is a ticking time bomb
how's that make you feel with everything
that's going on nowadays with the
identity theft and everything like that
and that police is all about that would
you be so kind just to leave me here
with the owners for two minutes please I
appreciate your feedback thank you guys
life
[Music]
you asked me here to come and help you
but you both need to change your ways
you won't open up to me and you won't
open up to each other your business is
literally dying because you won't
communicate but it's like you don't care
I can't even start to move forward
because I'm not feeling the [__] the
hunger
that both you want this place to work so
I'm just saying [__] it sell it
goodness this
not again
[__]
oh my gosh Gordon can't even find the
solution
it takes two takes two hands to get out
I love this place I love this place with
all my heart but the way things are
going
the Revelation is just not worth it
I really struggled to get through to
Chris and TJ the person who knows them
better than anyone is their mother Trudy
I'm hoping she may help me to unlock
that divide between them and hopefully
get these two back on track
okay
I mean I came to see this morning
because I need your help
I'm struggling to get through to TJ and
I'm struggling to get through to Chris
they don't communicate they don't drive
the business forward they just bicker
and butt heads why is that
I don't know
I don't know why
how much does that in mean to you I mean
what does it stand for in your family
stands for a lot of homework it's
nothing else yeah
we all had to work in there
reaping the rewards of the family
success and nearly six decades
but how would it make you feel with this
business was sold to a different family
now I mean all that work of you and your
husband's commitment
I don't want another better change yeah
I really don't want to see it go down
the street tomorrow
I want to see if those two can't come
back together and get it back on their
feet
I really want to help your family and I
really want to keep this business alive
for another 60 years so we're gonna have
to get them to talk to each other
otherwise the business is doomed well
you're right
and I need your help
please
you got it thank you I'll see you back
at the end okay okay thank you very much
coming up for the two of you be able to
communicate as brother and sister is
more important than even this in has
change come too late for the Curtis
house
foreign
house in Woodbury Connecticut is sinking
because the two owners won't speak to
each other and despite the hotel's dire
situation I've been unable to get
through to Chris and TJ come on Chris
you don't care
so I went to see their mum and I need
your help you got it now Trudy has
organized a family intervention to let
TJ and Chris know how much they're
fighting is hurting the inn and everyone
around them hi guys oh boy fuss all uh
to you guys I appreciate you being here
your mum has brought everyone together
just to talk to you from the bottom of
their hearts
I hope this is going to open your eyes
because right now I don't know what will
who'd like to go first Tess what have
you got to say my darling mom I think
that you're Spread Way Too Thin
we think that the mounting work is
getting to be too much you're getting
frustrated and eventually it's bound to
spill over but I think that for the two
of you to still be able to talk and
communicate as brother and sister is
more important than
even this in
currently
I've sat with both of you many times
talked about all the problems you guys
just go back and forth there's no
resolve nothing you have to get on the
same page about it it's way too much for
everyone in this place
it's awful something has to change
bye Bobby okay TJ and Chris I really
hope we can all get through this
this is so important
you've been here for 48 years you know
this place better than anybody the two
of you were so close to so many years I
know because I was there and I've seen
it
we used to come to work and do a job
I've been really enjoying working with
each other
and with both your stubbornness you took
that all away
sent you to stop speaking everything is
going downhill
I want to help you two get back together
like it used to be
the Curtis house can be that way again
and on YouTube can make that happen we
all want to be there for you and help
you
and with a lot of Hope and help from
Gordon's expertise we can get
Connecticut's oldest in Curtis house
back to where it should be
and you too then can be very very proud
of what you accomplished
sweetie my darling
can these two make it work
they sure can
sure can they have
and we're behind Dem 100.
well desperate
beyond belief
to help you make this place work
you both have to step up
[Music]
when he walks through the door I have to
be the person that's there for him
that's it
but
I wanted I want him to be my cat here
and I want to be the person he goes to
Chris G1 to make this work
[Music]
Chris and TJ's Family have come together
for a last-ditch attempt to say the
Curtis house in by getting them to talk
to each other again now Chris has to
decide if you'll commit to the Inn or
walk away Chris do you want to make this
work
absolutely
[Music]
it just sucks that we've gone this far
got to stop being a jerk especially to
my sister
now I really just want to make my mother
proud of my family proud it's been a
family establishment all these years and
I have to make them proud again
Christopher and I let everything else
get in the middle of our relationship we
have to be each other's number one you
know family first we can do it family
united makes a stronger front you ready
yes absolutely
that was the first time we've seen that
in three years
it was like we did it
TJ ready for change my design team has
worked all night to transform the Inn
and now it's time to reveal the new look
to the team welcome to the new Curtis
house Connecticut's oldest in
run by an extraordinary family providing
a warm and welcoming experience for
other families excited I can't wait
you're gonna love it are you ready to go
inside yes we are let's go follow me
please
please come in
oh my God look at this
wow
oh my God that is awesome welcome to
your amazing new Lobby it comes through
ladies
a de-cluttered very welcoming warm space
over here we have this stunning
silhouette they are historical portraits
of all your family
TJ come here come over here you okay
yeah the Silhouettes of the family and
the staff it put me over the edge
because this business was built on that
you need to celebrate your family
history not be trapped by it
now one thing that can send me on my
first arrival was the check-in and that
reservation book that was gathering all
that sensitive personal data come over
please
oh my God what is that oh my God a
computer
now we know they didn't have these in
1754 but you can okay the credit card
and all the personal details will be
safe we've had that red book for years
I'm so happy it's gone if Aunt TJ brings
the red book back out I will burn it
I'll do anything to make sure we never
see that thing again I'd like to take
you upstairs now uh to my room you ready
you'll be pleased to know we've repaired
the door handle so it actually works
oh my God
wow
again secret history but encapsulating
that modern Elegance the panels on the
wall Elevate the scope the depth of the
room TJ Betty the ghost has her own
cushion
I think Betty's going to be very happy
with what Gordon did I think she's going
to love the fact that she's become an
elegant feature so babe I want you to
come here please
stand there
back relax turn around
and we look at the eyes of that picture
I move your head from left to right
and the eyes move the eyes falling
around the room
oh my God the eye portrait it was really
creepy but I would try to stay in there
I might have another room on backup just
in case I couldn't make it through the
night but I would definitely give it a
try
ready to see another one this one you
gotta love it's my favorite one let's go
oh my gosh
beautiful what's that oh my God just
gorgeous I really feel the changes are
gonna help TJ and I get some things back
into Focus my father would definitely
like a lot of the the changes I wish I
was here to see it no you won't believe
what I have downstairs for you let's go
coming up I give babe a surprise she'll
never forget can I have a French kiss
[Music]
I'm just showing the family their new
Lobby oh my God and the new bedrooms oh
my gosh
now it's time to show them the new
improvements to the Hotel restaurant
the Yen has been in the Hardesty family
for four generations wow wow so I've
come up with a new menu that reflects
the family's history
the Curtis house family favorites
let's start off with Grandma Trudy's
crab cake they hit every single time
TJ's grilled salmon and corn Johnny
cakes Chris's country fried pork chop
dipped in buttermilk so with mac and
cheese gravy and green beans you're only
allowed it once a week
and when you're cooking your family's
food it's gonna be so much more love so
much more care to what you're serving
now tuck in and enjoy
[Music]
oh that sauce is unbelievable I'm really
excited to show off the new menu this is
a good one finally now this is something
I can tell people it's really really
good earring here is delicious very very
good it's like a new buggy right whole
new ball game just like us
tonight is the relaunch of the new
improved Curtis house as the guests
arrive there's a new sense of warmth and
welcome from TJ and the staff
welcome to the Curtis house how are you
I love the new look and I can't wait for
our customers to come into I want to see
their reaction got our own little
fireplace I love how it has that nice
cozy cottage feel but yet it matters
this is definitely going to get people
in the rooms and we're proud to send
them up there welcome to the Curtis
house thank you let me take you upstairs
to your room
down in the restaurant Chris is taking
charge and putting in the care he needs
to make his diners happy
cupcakes need to go in the oven please
it feels very good you know it's where
it should be definitely giving me a lot
more focus a little more Direction and a
little more immediate Pride yeah and use
this food for that please thank you come
on Chris we good we good
more importantly TJ and Chris are
working together and communicating yes
and then we got a clam and a slider
coming yes I think my brothers and my
attitude has changed dramatically plate
in my clams right now plating now thank
you my brother and I are back to working
very well together how do we go Jordan
we're doing fine I'm getting all kinds
of Power oh baby you're all right ma
you're all right it's definitely one of
the most important things to me is to
see my mother and my sister and my
family happy
TJ and Chris are finally working
together but I have one last thing I
need to do to help turn this business
around you must be dollar good to see
you thank you
I've asked a paranormal expert to
investigate the spirits haunting the Inn
somebody here
[Music]
's acting really foggy
[Laughter]
you are officially
a member of the Haunted Connecticut
tours and you are now officially haunted
congratulations thank you thank you very
much pride now that the Curtis house is
certified as haunted and on the ghost
tour it will attract even more business
and help this family get out of debt
uh ladies I'm gonna say goodbye
I know my job is done you two have been
amazing if they stop talking to each
other call me please I'm gonna miss you
oh no come on babe I'm gonna miss you
too little kiss
is
[Laughter]
Gordon did give me two kisses on my
cheek
yes I haven't washed it yet
[Music]
it's done I'm Gonna Leave You appreciate
it thank you very much yeah don't let 60
years of hard work disappear absolutely
not promise me you're gonna continue
talking to your sister the minute you
don't the place is doomed and you have a
beautiful beautiful in here thank you
very much I can't wait to come back
regardless please thank you Gordon
Ramsay put some life back into US good
night Bessie
Gordon showed us where our relationship
should be and will be from this point on
I'm forever grateful to Gordon Ramsay
for coming in here and straightening us
out
afraid of ghosts
since my visits TJ and Chris have
learned how important it is to work
together hot roasted chicken mashed only
turkey as it comes Gordon pulled off
something that I wasn't sure was going
to be able to be mended I think I got my
best friend back and he's not going
anywhere this time there you go there's
definitely ionic experience it's not a
Daily Grind now
bookings for the hotel are up if there's
any Spirits present in this room and
it's bringing in tourists who want to
get a glimpse of Betty the ghost good
evening welcome to the Curtis house if
Gordon didn't come I think we were
pretty much done you saved my family and
Miss Fields actually gave us our life
back
at the heart of Pipestone Minnesota
stands the historic Calumet Inn built in
1887. Calumet is a Native American word
for peace Bible but sadly peace is
something in short supply at the Calumet
Inn the hotel is owned by sisters Rina
and Vanda smergowsky
nine months ago their father Jim or
daddy as they call him purchased the
hotel for the Sisters I'm not sure that
Rina and evanda realize how privileged
they are just because we dress nice it
doesn't mean we're spoiled they are
definitely a little bit spoiled
green is not just a little bit spoiled
she's also a little bit of a crybaby
being judged you're gonna have to come
down to earth
God I cry a lot no what was I crying
about I don't even know
after owning the hotel for just six
weeks Marina found working a bit much so
she took the weekend off in Minneapolis
200 miles away and she didn't return for
three months
while she was away the hotel was left at
the mercy of her younger sister Banda
Vanda considers herself very hard
working although she doesn't get out of
bed until three o'clock every afternoon
leaving the hotel understaffed a lot of
times I feel like people come to work
and for their paycheck
[Music]
and they're not necessarily here to take
care of this historic artifact
I apologize again I'm sorry thank you
very much I do not think fan and Novena
should be running a hotel at all because
they don't know what they're doing and
they don't care about anybody
despite having zero Hospitality
experience you know how to use this
Vanda and Rina think they know best so
this trip the general manager of all her
management duties before Rina and Vanda
got here I was the general manager of
the Calumet and now I'm a front desk
person and a waitress that's what I am
I've got the chicken feeder wrap right
here with the girls in charge things at
the hotel have rapidly gone downhill
oh man
[Music]
how are your allergies doing
a little bit rough you need your inhaler
with almost no guests coming in Vanda
and rina's parents have been forced to
leave their family home in Minneapolis
and move into the hotel alongside their
daughters in a desperate attempt to cut
the costs and keep the doors open I'm
work seven days a week
I miss my home very much
if the situation doesn't change fast the
staff will all lose their jobs I can't
do this this is real life like this is
people's jobs this isn't you playing
Hotel because you're bored and the hotel
will have to shut its doors forever
if Gordon Ramsay cannot help Rina and
Vanda know but he can
and the Calumet will close
I'm in the middle of Minnesota look at
this place it's like Holland it is
incredibly flat windmills everywhere but
[__] tulips
[Music]
look at the size of that thing the
largest peace pipe in the world
is it wow this place is huge
and maybe a historical look at that
thing
okay
this is the entrance you're kidding me
this looks like the entrance of [__]
prison not a hotel
a prison with an ATM oh my God hello
you are killing me please
I can't believe it it's so dark in here
it's like a dungeon hello
solve this
and we're gonna get a light
that is crazy right
maybe it's best I turn around and [__]
off home now hello
I feel like a goonie
hey you guys
uh
oh hello Hi how are you when I saw
Gordon walk in I was very scared because
I knew that he was you know trying to
check into the hotel are you running
this place by yourself yesterday today
you are does anyone work in reception me
yeah are you ready yes so you were the
server and you're on foot desk yes my
name is Mandy Mandy Gordon nice to see
you you're busy yes Faber's indeed as
you've got dinos look after maybe
somebody else should check me in
I do not feel like a proper Jam here
[Music]
hey come down and help please feel like
somebody that's here to kind of cover
the extra hours however I do still get
to listen to the complaints I don't know
if you know Mandy but there's a bulb
missing there probably
Jim likes to take bulbs out of things so
people can't turn lights on Jim likes to
take bulbs yes Jim likes to take bulb
wow
take the bulb out
place in the Madhouse
oh hello hi finally finally and first
name is vanda vanda pleased to meet you
that way it's called good to see you I'm
Rena nice to see you sisters yes yes and
owners yes if you don't want to ask it I
mean you look very young to be running a
hotel how old are you I'm 27. wow maybe
I'm 32. wow babies
um and you both run it together yeah so
Mandy multitask she does the
restaurants she's um actually the
general manager
wow general manager head waitress and
she looks like a busser I'm not happy
with her work
it's really difficult to find people who
are motivated to work and who want to
live to live up to our standards
you are in our best room
The Melody of Love to hear people
shagging in the next door no you must
hear something else wow
holy mackerel
is that mold in there I I wouldn't be
surprised if it were mold
it's the uh wardrobe so I can hang my
jacket wardrobe um right over right
there
we kind of hidden behind the microwave
and moldy refrigerator
I'm feeling really nervous right now I
know that the room is really cluttered
but I didn't realize it was that bad
well at least we have a light bulb
there's a man that goes around nicking
light bulbs out of the lamps Mandy said
that he doesn't want them turned on
some guy called Jim my mother takes
light bulbs he's your father yeah mum
works in the business as well our mom
kind of goes around and
um helps clean up after people's mess
are they owners as well
so your parents bought you this place
yes
the moment we saw this place I knew I
had to have it so I found every single
way possible to convince my daddy no
matter what I had to do I just had
habits I personally think they could
have gotten it for cheaper and they
probably should have uh what do you two
do all day if mum and dad are hands on
so what's your role I do the bookkeeping
I do the front desk in the evening there
was one day Gordon I had to man the
dining room and the front desk I mean it
was big sis I don't know where you were
I think you're in Minneapolis or
something Minneapolis what were you
doing back there when you just bought a
hotel I actually needed some time to be
alone and figure things out so you take
two weeks away then what happened
she wasn't gone for two weeks she was
gone for three months
three months she's gone for three months
after being open for six weeks
I've heard your role what do you do I'm
seriously still confused what my role is
here I feel like I don't understand I
own the place you don't know what your
role is
I feel like a bunch of gas bubbles are
just flying all over molecules and atoms
just everywhere right now
did you stay here before you bought it I
stayed here um how many times
once
you stay one [__] night overnight did
you stay in here no not here in the
other room down the hall show me please
this is actually my favorite room
[Music]
okay and this is it so we stayed in this
room you stayed in this room this is
even worse than my room pee stains all
over the disgusting wallpaper holes in
the wall here
why is this hotel in such a state
we have a lot of problems with the staff
it's so hard Gordon to just repeat
myself what the problems rudeness
unprofessionalism there is a chronic
disease here of complaining and bitching
so we've got a big problem with the
staff yes you're
[Music]
you're welcome
I'm in Pipestone Minnesota in a place
run by two spoiled sisters whose Daddy
bought them a hotel
is that mold in there I wouldn't be
surprised they tell me the staff are the
biggest problem here it's so hard Gordon
to just repeat myself but I'm not so
sure she wasn't gone for two weeks she
was gone for three months
[Music]
hopefully some lunch will brighten up my
disappointing day hello how are you I'm
good how are you nice to meet you nice
to meet you I'm jazlyn Jocelyn nice to
see you how long have you been here I
have been here for two years two years
in June yeah it could be two years I'm
sorry yeah and is your father gonna buy
you a hotel
gonna happen even if I was like really
as I wanted just because I'm bored not
gonna happen right what would you
recommend do you want to start with an
appetizer maybe yeah what's the soup of
the day broccoli cauliflower yeah I'll
try one of those okay uh entrees uh
let's go for the fish the walleye strip
okay
um man it's a huge menu how many is in
the kitchen uh Two Two Chefs how'd you
get this food fresh with only two chefs
in the kitchen and a menu with literally
35 40 dishes on there
you don't
does it need rice our menu here is huge
I wish we could use better ingredients
here than in Reno they don't want to
spend
I would not spend my money here at the
restaurant no
hi Mandy Hi how are you busy you're
always running around yeah amazing I'm
how long have you been general manager
um two years two years no disrespect you
don't look like a general manager right
I'm not that anymore yeah sure seriously
seriously did you ever falling out with
them because no everybody's incompetent
apparently right I'm sick of not really
being the general manager I kind of feel
like I'm being pulled in all different
directions I don't really have a say in
anything how would you describe the
owners Amanda's borderline sociopath
um the other one I don't know I can't
describe her she's never here so
I appreciate you want to say thank you
wow Mandy
I suppose if I was working as hard as
hard as and the owner saw the stuff
too broccoli cauliflower right get your
new drink thank you
[Music]
so sorry
taste it just a small bit I don't look
it is absolutely [__] disgusting does
Jeff not care
no no I don't think the cooks care
anymore but I feel like a lot of us have
gotten to that point
[Music]
okay walleye fish trip chosen a strip
it's like a ball honestly how hot is
that thing I've never had it because I
don't like it is it fresh or frozen
frozen but it looks like crap so I
wouldn't eat it
that's what it takes uh yeah that is
disgusting
[Music]
spots everything who's the most
assertive about the sisters Fiona
because rina's not here no how committed
are they to running the business don't
care I think they look at it as like
well I own it so we can do whatever we
want sleep till three in the afternoon
keep the bar open until five in the
morning I mean how do you respect
somebody who does that oh no no no no no
no no
you're welcome
the food here is horrific is if the chef
is cooking enough sleep Gordon wants to
talk to you guys now you don't need me
here to tell you the soup is that
disgusting that even before anybody
tasting it it smells burnt this is why
we make our own food
I don't stand here anymore unbelievable
right now I've got no idea
what is going on here have you given up
young lady do you hate food
what's going on
you used to love my job
you know I hate it
I can see what's not working for you any
owners I'm not going to tolerate
disrespect you know we're not getting
paid we're not paying ourselves China's
owners complain about not being paid
[__] own the place
they don't have ownership of this
historic building
yeah daddy's not paying for everything
can I tell you something Gordon
Jen has called herself the best cook in
town she's picking on her you have
turned every [__] member of Staff
against you
I used to be really chirpy and happy and
I I can't even smile anymore
it's not about you yeah and I can't even
I can't even motivate myself to do my
projects anymore again just listen to
both of you
kill me kill me kill me you're only as
good as a team underneath you whether
you're here three months a [__] year
or three hours a day it doesn't matter
yeah yeah
grow up
people have heard that I'm in Pipestone
Minnesota's Calumet Inn I don't know if
you have any openings oh yes and the
hotel is starting to fill up with guests
look at the hole on the door I feel
sorry for all of them
yes well the first time my pasta was
burnt I purposely got the same thing to
see if it was any better and it's it's
not very sorry about the wheat
where am I oh my God ah sorry Jesus you
want some help no I got it thank you how
many chapters you got left to serve at
least two three four five yeah five the
size of the menu two Cooks behind the
line oh yeah ridiculous I don't get it I
mean I don't know how any standard can
be kept don't get it with the place this
busy it should be all hands on deck but
it's not uh where's that Arena I think
she's on the office apparently she's not
there
okay now the place is massive
volunteer I want to help people are you
up here
you okay yeah
yeah hi can I come in yeah
wow
hi oh this is my mom urina's mum great
to meet you
are you okay I'm okay but you look like
you've been crying for the last hour
I just didn't feel like being around
people right now I guess Richard because
she always run away when things get hard
[Music]
very obvious is the lack of commitment I
feel like we should have purchased a
duplex or something like that
[Music]
it's a bit late to think that now I just
can't seem to get up I know and do what
I have to do are you capable of holding
the reins here I want to start taking
control but I need room to grow I need
base for me to take charge
you need to get a great
how about getting changed and coming
downstairs and just facing the music
I can do that thank you thank you while
Wayne has been upstairs crying about
nothing her guests downstairs have every
reason to be upset how was your chicken
it was really dry
honestly one of the driest chicken
burgers I've ever had she can bring the
check I'll be happy this place is a
train wreck all right and the coffee's
complimentary so oh that's wonderful and
they will bring you up a pot to your
room thank you very much you're welcome
Vander Arena might not treat her like a
general manager but Mandy sure works
like one please have a little word down
the end of the dining room together two
minutes I want to tell Gordon if things
don't change
nobody's going to be here the Calumet
will close you strive me as the owner
because you are so busy every time
you're running in the battle in the
lounge in reception customers I hate I
hate that I can see how much it needs
you it's too old do they know that you
can run this place no we are all
incompetent to them wow what frustrates
you most about the two sisters band is a
micromanager she's very um cynical she
doesn't even get up off her ass and help
if it's busy she doesn't care well this
is what makes my house payment I do and
Rina is a pansy can't stand that what is
good at doing
cry no
are they qualified to run this business
no they should go out and work in the
real world first and the rest of Staff
your team that work under you there is
so much bitterness towards the owners
has this been building up people are
about to explode
the biggest problem at the hotel is the
ownership who are supposed to respect
ultimately doesn't respect us and I
think that makes people really not want
to be a part of this team the only
shining line in this building right now
is you because if you weren't here there
would be [__]
[Music]
I don't think van and Arena have a clue
about how much they've really upset
their staff with their absences and
their high-handed behavior I need to get
the staff and the owners in one room and
try to get them to communicate okay when
was the last time all of you had a
meeting when we first purchased this
place so nine months ago
we're just so burnt out Gordon so are we
first of all you guys I think you guys
need to understand that we live like
among in four corner walls and we have
no Escape we have we're living there
nobody made you stay and live here you
know what I think I think we know what
the problem is we stepped in their
territory and they cannot let go of
their egos here's the problem if you all
[__] got to work I wouldn't be so
[__] mad all the time I know one
thing that I come to work and I do my
job where the [__] are you Mandy what
kind of effect does that have on the
team when you can't get a word from your
owners it's really annoying it's um it's
passive aggressive behavior it makes
people just very un you know they don't
want to talk to you then fine you don't
want to talk to us we don't want to talk
to you there's attitude I do but when we
do there's attitude okay that [__]
starts with you too then see that's fine
no emotions I want if you are committed
committed [__] you I've been here for
three and a half years I've done
everything from bartender in the [__]
Pub to housekeeping to front desk to
serving we want to know that you're
gonna be here that's the thing
I'm [__] done I'm [__] done [__]
off committed you stupid [__] you just
got here
I work 65 [__] hours a week sometimes
70 and I have two [__] kids I'm a
single [__] mom it feels like I'm in
a woman's [__] prison
[Music]
I'm trying to say pipestones Minnesota's
Calumet in but Mandy the general manager
of three years the only shining line in
this building right now is you
have just quit her job
committed you stupid [__] you just
[Music]
I know a lot of people feel that if
Mandy's gone I'm gone I'm gone I'm gone
I'm gone I mean this is getting real
ugly our general manager has just walked
out
you know the funny thing is you no no no
listen it's not funny that girl
dedicated her life to keeping you in a
hotel have you ever employed one single
member of Staff she even worked a day in
her life how could you say that you
can't say that you don't know me at all
if you want to do these things I do them
but you guys don't see it you don't know
the life behind all you have no clue
for [__] sake one of you step up
if you were my daughters
I'd kick you out
you can laugh all you [__] once I'm
not your father but what I do know is
you don't [__] deserve this
thank you for the first meeting in nine
months
I thought Gordon was gonna be nice to me
that was extraordinary the only person
actually cared about this place
Mandy the general manager has gone those
daughters are absolutely screwed
[Music]
I'll sleep I need to get some exercise
to burn off some of the tension from all
that screaming last night
Hi how are you hi brother how are you
I'm good of course
I go to the gym and do some workout and
awesome
what floor is it on it's not we don't
have one in the building there's one
right over there
yeah
everywhere right over here like down the
street
like a Rec Center so I have to go out of
the hotel
no chance it's a ridiculous it's not
that a hotel this size with no gym on
site is just another example of van and
Arena forgetting who's most important
around here
good morning
it's a little ketchup hopefully today I
can finally get through to them good
morning
these are
some of your guests all I'd like to hear
is just nothing but the plain truth and
give these owners an insight to what
you're paying for
so let's start with yours um I'll tell
you the room was very disappointing we
look for historic buildings when we go
places and this was just a shame it was
like it was neglected it was run down to
the ground before we purchased this
place
you've got to stop blaming people
well when we came in we actually came in
the back way this dark hallway where
like coming through an entrance to a
prison yeah
[Music]
button please I have severe asthma and
allergies dusting the top of the
doorways and just caked and white dust
and oh my God it went beyond a comfort
issue this went to a health hazard issue
I was literally worried about my
fiance's safety and the last thing this
place needs is some kind of you know
wrongful death liability
would any of you come back to stay here
absolutely not
not one of it thank you thank you guys
thank you Take Care thank you I'm so
sorry the complaints from guests are
obvious things that a hotel owner should
be taken care of but these girls haven't
got a clue or a general manager do you
honestly think that you are capable of
running this hotel when I want something
bad enough and when I have my mind up to
it I always I always accomplish at 32
years of age tell me one thing that
you've accomplished in your life on your
own
I worked when I was 14.
at a fast food place
are you serious you want me to get
impressed with that no I'm not
Commander do you honestly think that you
and your big sister are capable of
running this hotel I want to say yes but
I just
my head says no
I feel like a knife has just been
running to my heart
but I can run this place by myself
you have to be honest with yourself I
think we can make it with the positive
reinforcement that I use I would [__]
myself asking you to run my dog up the
hill let alone our hotel
Pipestone Minnesota's Calumet Inn is in
a dreadful State the food is awful it is
absolutely [__] disgusting and the
rooms are just as bad that's moldy oh
man and the owners are totally useless I
would [__] myself asking you to run my
dog up the hill let alone a hotel
there's only one person that can help me
save this place
unless I can convince Mandy to come back
and take on the role as their general
manager then quite frankly Arena and
Vanda are screwed and I'll tell them to
close the hotel tonight
[Music]
we got two minutes
you had to be right to walk out how you
feeling better but I'm okay
yeah watching the way you work and the
way you feel for the place and how much
energy you put in to that hotel
you are a bloody good general manager I
think you know your job thank you if you
were given the absolute control of that
place to run it
would you come back
it's tough I just I don't like them
I know and after everything that's been
said I don't
I mean I
I don't know I just
I don't know
if I was Mandy I don't know what I'd do
either
[Music]
I really don't know what's going to
happen at this hotel
Arena Randa capable of change do they
have it in them to shoulder the
responsibility of this hotel
I need to have a proper chat with their
mum
hello
hi it smells incredible up here
I am cooking green curry it smells
incredible and who's uh whose recipes
are these oh
I just make up would you mind about a
little taste yeah sure a little bit
spicy maybe that's perfect that is
absolutely perfect my God hmm
wow that's delicious that's the tastiest
food thank you I haven't eaten since
I've been here thank you amazing you're
a very very good cook
how many times a week do you cook for
your daughters seven days a week
those babies need to grow up yeah I know
that I could I spoil them when was the
last time you had a brain
huh
not at all
sometime I get frustrated I tell them
you need to do the workout by yourself
Rina and Vanda treat their mother as
their personal chef so she's stuck at
the hotel working seven days a week it's
time the girls grew up I wanted to talk
to all four of you to shed some light
if you want to teach your daughters
responsibility like I have to as a
father with three daughters I buy them a
[__] goldfish
not a hotel
Jim do you want to be here
I wouldn't want to stay here on a
permanent basis
Rita
no no
do you want to be here
no I don't
right now
I'm not happy here
I'm not I'll be honest
that's not what monster we're doing I'm
asking you do you want to be here
I don't think you do either you need to
go back to Minneapolis you need to get
into the city that's what you need to do
thank you
[Music]
oh
yeah
thank you
all right there's just something I've
been afraid to say
each one of you are actually trapped
inside this hotel what do we do I would
like you to decide as a family enjoyed a
proper general manager to run the hotel
for you or do you want to sell it or
shut it down
decision is yours
coming up the family has come to a
decision about whether to close the
doors of this historic Calumet Inn
I'm very sorry
the owners of Pipestone Minnesota's
historic Calumet Inn have made a
decision about whether to shut the hotel
down sell it or get a proper general
manager to run it for them
no idea what's gonna happen I'm nervous
I'm very sorry for the way that you guys
have been treated and we have made a
decision here that will turn this place
around
and
that means us stepping out of the
picture
tomorrow
there is going to be a new general
manager here somebody actually in charge
someone with the authority from the
owners to run this place on their behalf
stay there hope you get them for you
please
ladies and gentlemen let me introduce
you to the calumet's new general manager
good to see you sellers your team after
talking with Gordon I realized everybody
that works there is like my second
family I care too much about the Calumet
to allow the doors to be closed I'm
pleased you're back
you are an asset to this hotel
these two young girls
are leaving this hotel this is exactly
what I've wanted all along I've always
wanted a true general manager to run the
place and I would come here on the
weekends to help out with the
decorations they know that it's not
healthy they know they can't continue oh
I'm beyond ready to give Mandy you know
full reins and full control as general
manager I have full faith in her she's a
very powerful very competent very strong
lady tomorrow we are relaunching this
hotel in the new management
and there are going to be a lot of
changes I want all of you to get out of
it and get some rest because tomorrow is
one hell of a day yeah thank you today
everyone wins as the family is free to
leave Pipestone the staff get a proper
leader and Mandy gets the freedom to be
in charge and overnight the interior of
this historic building has got what it
has long deserved to a wonderful
transformation good morning hi welcome
to the new Calumet Inn this is
incredibly historic and a very special
hotel but now it's somewhere where
guests are going to be incredibly well
looked after come with me let's go
ladies
[Music]
I take it you like it I love it goal is
that disgusting wallpaper now we have a
stunning
bright colorful paint of Kelly Green new
mattress new box frame new linen new
cushions and a bed to absolutely
disappearing notice how bright it is
let's try and keep the bulbs in the
fixtures gym especially in that rear
entrance tunnel
John is that Dreadful rail in the corner
we replaced that with a wonderful tall
wardrobe how nice is that oh yeah
beforehand the jacuzzi looks awkward now
we've framed the bathtub with these
beautiful custom drapes so you can
highlight the fact that it's a stunning
jacuzzi but we've given it his own space
I'm blown away I mean you know guests
are actually going to be happy to spend
their honeymoons here and we're going to
be proud to actually show this room this
one is really special I mean yeah it's a
a new addition please welcome to my
favorite room jump in there
let's go
[Applause]
on it's the bedroom you now have a
fabulous Unique Fitness Center
where yes like myself do not have to
walk 100 meters it's room is actually
what everybody needs in here when people
are stressed out when they want to kill
each other they can just go in there and
just relax can we take a seat please
I've got something that is really going
to put this hotel on the map
the food before like the heart you would
get from home cooking turns out the
answer was right under her noses Rita
we've adapted your cooking style
Rita's Thai specials
Rita when I tasted your food upstairs my
dolly I was blown away oh yeah now the
legacy is going to continue a stunning
beef Satay and then a delicious green
chicken curry and a phenomenal Pad Thai
thank you ladies come on
this is real time Rita what do you think
we're done excellent yeah yep I am very
excited to see my Thai food on the menu
it tastes very good yes
thank you
[Applause]
okay are we ready ready okay all good
I'm ready with our rejuvenated energy
the staff are ready for the first night
of the calumet's new life well welcome
to the Calumet Inn my name is Mandy
general manager how are we doing tonight
good all right we have a new menu
five seconds good luck thank you you can
do this oh this is a whole new level of
Thai food it's fresh really excited
about that something I've always wanted
to do and for the first time parents Jim
and Rita are enjoying their investment
instead of having to work at it a
thousand percent better keep up the good
work yeah yeah
when money agree to return it was on the
condition that Rina and Vanda would be
out of the picture unfortunately these
sisters can't stop interfering are we
good
okay all right enjoy oh how you doing
tonight do you have a wine list I can go
grab you one
they remade our wine list I have no idea
Hotel can't afford to lose Mandy again
with so much at stake I've got to step
in what are you doing I
meeting and reading the gospel
you swallowing around looking like
you're here to take the cream because
you want to meet and greet the guess
you've actually done [__] all tonight
get back upstairs and pack now
[Music]
the calumet's relaunch is going well and
the team are handling more guests than
hotel has seen in years two rivers and a
spirit I got it the guests are loving
the new rooms upstairs definitely like
the color the green really makes it
bright it's a nice mix of old and new
yeah okay yep come back and I'm really
pleased to see Mandy stepping up and
taking control of a team as the general
manager I have to communicate with the
kitchen a little bit better there's Just
One Last Detail to address Rina and
Vanda need to hit the road
hello Vanda are you finished packing yet
the Taxi's on its way I'm going
okay ladies
yes he's here
good luck okay thank you a little
present for you to teach you
responsibility back in Minneapolis
please
now look after them once you've got the
hanger looking after those then we can
step up to a cat Okay the cat's fine
then we go to a dog look out those fish
good night I'm gonna go off and pursue
my dreams
um I'm gonna
travel and continue onwards into my 30s
a happy person not miserable
don't drop it it will not drop the
goldfish
I'm going back to Minneapolis but I'm
really excited to feel free to let out
my creativity and show the world what
I'm capable of look one is bigger when
it's smaller the bigger one can be Rina
the lemon can be Panda
what a week when I first arrived I were
two small brats that were playing at
running a hotel
the change has been extraordinary the
key to the turnaround was in Mandy
coming back and standing strong as a
proper general manager
this time it's a proper goodbye
and I cannot wait to come back and see
awesome I believe in you you already
have made a big difference good luck
with it thank you well done thank you so
much
I feel like a whole new person I am
ready to just go full bore with this
thank you so much Gordon for giving me
my job back and for believing in me
goldfish survive it's 50 50.